all right i really want your take on
these all right first up tinks uh metro
reports singles are trying out something
called the zero date and it's a predate
to decide if they even want to go on a
first date and you can do it on the
phone or on zoom so after you meet
online you just sort of make an
appointment to do this it's quick you
can feel each other out just a little
tiny nibble and see if you want to order
the whole entree and then maybe have
dessert later if you know what i mean
but i mean do you recommend this
especially for online daters to do some
sort of facey time thing i like it i
like it as a little bit of a pre-check
because how many times have you sat down
at a at a drink state or even worse a
dinner date yeah and immediately first
five seconds you you know there's just
no dice like we are just not to get
along there's nothing for us to talk
about we don't vibe and oftentimes you
know you connect with someone so
instantly so why not give them a quick
facetime exactly and then it's so great
you know you're not going to be
catfished exactly you have that you
don't have the insecurity of are they
going to think i'm cute in person hello
they just saw you make sure you hold the
angle here hold it here
like the person had the one yeah like a
little bit
yeah you know set this the scene let me
ask you some advice because this is
something i've just recently learned um
i had gone on some dates over the last
few years and they were always a meal
and i did have a couple circumstances
okay see your reaction says it all you
can't you can't do a first dinner date
okay thank you then you're like why
didn't you do this
oh my god haven't you ever gone to
dinner date you sit down and like you
haven't even gotten bread yet and you're
already like so where did where did you
grow up you said and you're just like
pulling in straws to keep it going you
go with almost all of yeah yeah exactly
and then you're like trying to eat your
pasta and keep the conversation going
and appetizers are mains you're like
yeah you're like jack jack
and of course
i can't not being i
yeah and then i also want to be like
give it a minute like yeah but i'm like
but not
maybe a minute not exactly 72 exactly
exactly after living and learning i
agree
well this i like we've got some good
news in the fight against ghosting i
love that
we have some good news in the fight
against ghosting if that didn't happen
hello
nothing will fast company reports there
is a new dating app called snack and
it's taking steps to actually ghost the
ghosts
users can report someone
when they have just disappeared on them
and the app will flag those profiles and
slowly make them less visible
to everyone else kind of put them down
lower in the line if you know what i
mean
so ghosts you've been poofed yes so i
like it yeah what comes around
goes around oh yeah
i love that i love that so much because
you know what ghosting is very cowardly
and it's i don't think that we should be
encouraging that type of dating how hard
is it to send a text or a message you
know sorry i didn't like that you know i
didn't vibe with you on the first date
best of luck out there it takes two
seconds you know and it seems so scary
but it's just the adult mature honest
kind thing to do
[Music]